what a new video three days in a row I
think it's three days in a row okay how
does one get started with the best
programming language C++
well easy you google it tank I just
ruined my watch time by giving you the
answer oh wait I just ruined all of
YouTube's watch time for all how-to
videos okay I guess this better be good
if you're gonna continue watching it
okay so
I will explain in the quickest and most
succinct wonderful way ever and at the
end of this video I'll show you how you
can get this cool background I have I
don't know why I said that but I guess
I'm gonna do it now and maybe that'll
actually make people watch because I
know none of you are dedicated enough to
actually program that's rare that's like
one in a million I think I feel like I'm
the only person in the world other than
like the rare never mind off topic
alright so if you want to get started
programming with C++ on Windows you're
going to need Visual Studio it's free
Community Edition you have a secondary
option you can use cygwin which sort of
replicates on length a Linux terminal
those are the main two ways just either
do a visual studio or you do it with
cygwin and use uh pretty much like a
Linux compiler so if you're following
for example if you're following a
tutorial says here's how you get started
here's how you do stuff on Linux you can
go get cygwin and install cygwin and you
pretty much have a fake version of Linux
or at least a console there are other
options or other IDs there are other
compilers I'm not going to get on into
that then you probably just want to do
visual studio or cygwin just keep it
simple here and look look how hard this
is oh my god oh my god so hard
programming so hard how would I how do I
ever get started how do it yeah it's
literally this simple like blows my mind
when people ask me questions because I'm
like do you have the internet they're
like oh cores to go at the Internet's I
couldn't what do you what do you asking
me for I'm not gonna tell you anything
you don't already know how to type at
least I oh there you go this is it
community edition the other ones cost
money and yeah communities for up to
three people I think on a project so if
you're just getting started you're not
gonna have more than three people anyway
yeah so you install it and when Visual
Studio when you hit the installer it's
gonna prompt you for some stuff just
choose the C++ options and look getting
started
first app that's it so the the next step
really is oh god how do I ever learn C++
Wow how can I ever find any anyone to
teach me this difficult language I I
don't know maybe maybe you could just go
boy like everything else
Oh God so yeah there you go
there's a little literally how you learn
if you want like really specific things
keep watching
I'll show you a few things when we get
to the end I will show you how to get
this the sweet retro whatever background
awesome background okay so let's let's
start with cygwin say say you want to do
this Linux style you're old school or
ureña you're in a school and they say
we're gonna use Linux everywhere and
you've got to come to our lab to to
program because we have Linux and or
install Linux on your own machine or or
go get a whatever environment install
Linux on your Windows computer through a
virtual machine and hago your hard drive
space and then when you you know don't
do that do not install a whatever you
know what I'm trying to say don't just
don't it's it's not worth it you in just
two sick minutes and it's like natively
fast so the first thing you want to get
kinda want to do is check some stuff out
oh yeah this is kind of important if
you're doing it on Linux you're gonna
need to know bash commands and there and
how do you learn those do I need to
teach you all them or can you just
Google I mean you're watching this on
the internet so I'm guessing you have
the internet so Google you wonder what
LS does here's a hot here's a hot tip of
how to find out
you just you figure it out
alright so LS lists your files and yeah
you can just see all these there there's
tons of them so if you want to see cheat
sheets of them have at it
okay I just revealed the biggest secret
of programmers I mean if you're not a
programmer you probably think that
programmers like have spent a lot of
time studying and figured things out yes
they have and they have some kind of
secret knowledge no they don't they've
google it they spent a lot of time
googling when they have a question they
give it and if you don't get the answer
you're not asking the right question
because it's probably out there if you
run into something that it's not on
Google then you're into a hard
programming and that's pretty rare only
I get it that far
all right touch updates the time stamp
on a file or file doesn't exist it
creates it so that's pretty useful one
so this dot text for example
now look I got a file called this text
all right that's pretty random let's
make a directory with make dirt that's
pretty important one two and I'm just
gonna call a two-bit that makes a folder
that's what that does so CD has changed
directory so I went to the folder and if
I want to go on a move that this dot
text on this folder I can do let's see a
copy or move either either works
let's do move go back a directory with
dot dot and then slash this dot text
where are we moving it to where are we
already are I think that's right see I
do it right here I do it right yeah just
a dot is where you are so we put dot the
healing to do that usually but I don't
know let's let's make us he boss plus
file so I'm gonna make a main file I'm
gonna open it here's a here's a cool
trick if you have Visual Studio code and
you're using cygwin because you want to
do that a Linux environment thing oh how
do you get Visual Studio code Oh
oh I don't know it's so hard I it's
gonna be a lot of explaining I hate like
there's just so much man ice I don't
know how to get it it's one of the most
difficult just kidding yeah you know if
you haven't figured out already that I'm
pretty much it's gonna pay to Google
everything sort of explained it eat some
sort cast that's that's what all right
so I touched a Maine dot CPP file which
means one now exists another thing
you're going to want to learn and this
is actually kind of hard
I will admit is make files how do you
how do you learn how you make files make
files how to I found make to be a little
I mean okay make files are actually
really simple there's only a few things
you actually need to know but it seems
like every guide overcomplicates it I
feel like every C++ guide sort of
overcomplicates it - maybe I'm over
complicating it but I'm giving you the
answers so you can't complain that much
well anyway about back to that Visual
Studio code thing that I got sidetracked
on you can type code to launch Visual
Studio code and if you want to open the
folder you're in you can I think it's
just dot slash yeah and that will open
the folder you're currently in into
Visual Studio code and you can open
individual files the same way like so
and it'll just pop up in a new tab so
that's a cool way you can kind of
integrate these two together at least on
Windows I don't know how well terminal
things work on other OS is and with
other things I can't speak to that I
know it doesn't do it on like Linux or
why don't I do it on Linux I don't know
you can probably there's probably a way
to do it probably all right so we've got
our main dot cpp so i'm gonna show you
what everyone shows you every time
they're like hey so you want to learn
C++ maybe what I'll show you something
I'll show you something super cool hello
world hello world if I'm not gonna I'm
gonna google it [ __ ]
that's oh yeah and don't forget your new
line
don't forget your new line and this is
actually a function that returns an N so
you better return an int and isn't it
when I return zero don't and it also
doesn't matter so I don't know I guess
it used to but a lot of people like to
do this thing where they do see n the
end or C end I get that way you have to
press Enter
you actually exit the program to see end
get we'll just wait for you to enter a
character in the console
he's a C on CN its console line console
well so they've run in your consoles STD
is not for standard templated disease
its standard it stands for standard if
you never want to type them you can do
it's a namespace thing you want to learn
about namespaces you can do it's not
really that important right at the very
beginning but eventually you'll learn
more about them I'm not going to get
into that because this is just way too
new for that all right so we could run
this this is a complete enough program
to run so if we go back to cygwin you
can compile it with g plus plus if you
want to aversion of g plus plus you
you can do G + + - v and I'll tell you
all about the version
look at that alright let's see
bread model POSIX GCC version 7.4 this
is sort of important sometimes if you're
doing advanced things and we need to
know what version you're on or what you
can do as c++ is still being developed
and features are being added so I can
compile this with G + + and I want to
compile my CV and it'll just do it
that's literally all you need to do to
compile your poor first program so this
is a program that can run on your
computer any computer you compile it on
any computer the other thing about c++
the compiler is generally version
specific to your hardware I'm not saying
that right but it compiles based on your
hardware so if you go to another machine
you can't just take drag this X cube
over on a on a flash drive and run it
you want to take the source code and
recompile it that way it compiles for
their machine and that way it can be
optimized c++ optimizes as it compiles
that's the super cool thing about it you
don't get that with java java you get a
just-in-time compiler or a JIT compiler
also known as a shitty compiler c-sharp
does that too that's why they're so slow
don't take this too seriously I'm sort
of just ragging on but that part is true
they they do compile at runtime and
that's why you need Java Runtime
environment in dotnet for your yeah I
don't know how exactly what c-sharp is
but don net is something to do with it
I'm sure someone will reel me in the
comments about it like they did on my
last programming video all right so you
don't you can run your executable within
dot slash and then the name of the
program all also you can press tab to
autocomplete
if it there's no other viable option I'm
gonna pick the one that's there all
right so we get exactly what we console
outed and it's now sitting here at this
C and I get in wait of course that's why
it hasn't exited yes
wax it so for example to comment this
out comments the slashes of course
you'll figure that out on your first
tutorial and run it again it's gonna do
the exact same thing oh that might be
confusing why is it still waiting for it
when it's commented out if you already
know the answer you're ahead of the
curve we have to recompile it we're
still on the same one so we have to do
this g plus plus thing again and do main
to G again and it'll recompile it now
with that comment it out so it'll just
exit right away right back to the
console there we go
okay so that's how that's a way you can
get started working with cygwin you can
use whatever editor you want you to want
to use Visual Studio code but I feel
like it integrates very nicely and you
and it has add-ons and so it's a very
nice one it's probably the best in my
opinion I'd rate it number one as far as
open source editors go alright so that's
how you deal with cygwin so what if
you're using Visual Studio well expect
hold on for go Visual Studio I'm gonna
show you something else about State
women's it's sort of obscure but sort of
sort of important let me see my
downloads here okay so I got so when you
download this set up for cygwin and run
it you get this and this is also how you
update cygwin and this is how you
install new packages on cygwin as you
run this executable again so hang on to
it or you can just go download it again
doesn't matter and there's another
spoiler in this downloads thing don't
look
alright so hit next the next don't
change any of these options if you mess
around changing these options I can't
help you and I don't I don't care so
don't ask me for helping you change the
default options and yeah you just hit
next until it does this pre-dinner
through them if you want basically you
can do special things with cygwin to set
up in a special way but don't have to
100% optional so you get to this point
this is a little confusing at first you
have a view here of what of what you're
looking at starts out with pending so
anytime you run this it's going to check
your currency
when installed and see what you need to
update and it's just gonna update
anything that's out of date so you want
to run this every once in a while or run
it when you start computer whatever you
want to do but you can go to this and
look at different things like let's look
at you probably won't look at not
installed and search for like gee plus
plus these are additional ones that I
don't need but if you do this you'll get
a GCC one and this is the one you need
to compile like I'm compiling unless you
need something special you also probably
want to go ahead and get make let's see
probably want to see make he might not
need it I don't have it right now
probably want Auto make and you probably
want to make you definitely need to make
and you might as well get ought to make
some things rely on it and there may be
other things but this is how you go get
packages is the point and then after you
do you check what you want I don't know
for example let's let's do something new
I'll get I'll go ahead and get C make
you click on the bin right here no you
don't you click on this drop-down and
you click on which one you want and
you'll see you get some stuff here do
you want the source code for it not all
that source code if you do you can do it
now you go you just hit next it picks
everything it needs and installs it for
you and your say when it's set up with
new stuff so if you're missing something
it tells you you're missing something
when you're trying to do something on
cygwin you can go do that
alright on the visual studio now so if
you use a visual studio to your C++
project you get this after you finally
install it so you probably just want to
do create a new project and you do a
console app or an empty project we're
gonna do a console app
and yeah okay so this starter package
doesn't matter a whole lot because once
you're in your program you can change
things and do whatever you want so it's
not like you have to stick to whatever
they start you out with and you get some
some basic a basic guide you know
there's kind of the thing we did in uh
and sig one now we're here on your left
side this is not a folder structure I
know it looks like one but it's not this
is actually like special directories I
can you go to where this is you will not
see these folders so this is like a
special sort that Visual Studio does if
you want to see real folders and you've
got a click show all files yeah so this
is what's actually and your folder is
just this one CPP file and there's
probably stuff up above it but this is
like your main project so yeah this is
just like a sort so eventually if you
keep if you stay like this and you keep
adding stuff and doing stuff eventually
when you do go to your folder you'll
just see a giant list of files with no
folders and it's really ugly
so I usually actually recommend going to
this show all files and making some
folders on your own add a new folder and
then do stuff like this and rename all
this source maybe etc etc so and you can
still go back to this view and and see
them in this special sort if you want to
even actually have your own special set
up alright so this is the same thing it
tells you told you some getting started
stuff I'm just gonna hit hit play I'm in
debug I'm in x86 that's mining SP you
can do different versions too and it
does it tells you some more crap press
any key to close this window ok so what
if we do a standard yeah and yeah like
we did our other one notice they're also
not returning his Ellie so like a new
thing why is this into even here then
honestly it should be void you're not
returning anything it's void
you'll learn that too as you start
making more functional so sort of a
weird thing he asked me but whatever as
you see it stopped us again just the
same and we get an attorney should
congenic continue i guess they've got
this special thing where it's press any
key to continue i think this is because
debug is on I think it does this just to
help you debug so if we switch this to
release we'll probably have something
else happen all right here we are press
our injury nope still does the same
thing so there's there's how you can get
started with C++ programming on on
Windows and if you want to go further I
highly recommend just googling it
googling C++ you probably already given
you the first one or two tutorials that
you'll find so you can skip to the next
part where they teach you about I don't
know
variables like stuff like cares
characters and integers and whatever you
know doubles floats load
ah so in any of these you'll figure it
out soon but you know the type the name
if you want to include more libraries
and stuff play around with more packages
do it at the top and I'm not gonna go
any further than that but I do want to
show you one last thing as a little
bonus is still going good see make this
huge or my internet slow I don't know
which one but let's go ahead and watch
the cygwin
it's probably gonna bug out my little
installer thing but I don't care so
we're gonna go on that folder we have
our main I want to teach you about
making files so I'm gonna touch them
file and now we're gonna make file in
there unless let's just go ahead and
code up this big cool thing about make
files you don't need to know this you're
doing if you're doing it on Windows
normally this is more of a Linux thing
also there's this program called see
make it's actually the one I'm
installing that makes these for you
so you don't necessarily need to know it
these can be super nice if you're doing
your own project and it's like you have
your own mole set up basically this is
sort of like a we call the build file
but it's actually more of a bash command
runner and just run like all these
little things I'm typing in bash over
here make files just run a bunch of
those basically and whatever you want
there it's sort of intended to build
program but you could you can do
anything with it you could just run bash
command so if you're learning bash
really well you probably want to learn
make does this make you can like program
bashed up but there's also just bash
files for that too so one thing you
learn after a while is there's like a
million different ways of doing
everything it's like oh you can do it
this way or that way or that way so
which is best I don't know let's waste a
whole week trying to figure out the best
way where we could just get it done
that's one of my pet peeves - all this
stuff actually is that there's just so
many ways to do the same thing and it's
hard to figure out which is the best one
the best one is usually the one that
actually gets it done
so you have to sit there and contemplate
you're doing it wrong
just just pick one go for it if it
doesn't work try different then you try
to alright make files how do you make a
make file like if I want to make a make
file to makes the program that run name
run Z you just type make it'll run
whatever make files in the folder your
if I type make right now it'll execute
the make file that's in this folder this
one and do like a name of something a
colon and then the files you want it to
look at song the splitter my CPP and
then down below you tab over this has to
be a tab if it's spaces it won't work
I'll make sure it's actually tap tab
over and type in the command we know
it's G + + and main dot C so if I type
make it'll look at my main dot CPP and
if it has been updated since the last
time I ran make you don't run this
command so the cool thing it does is it
checks if your files have been updated
since the last time you ran make and
that way you don't redundantly build the
same thing over and over so I type make
ill building
I type me again apparently build it
again I don't know I don't know if it's
actually building I think it actually
did hmm it shouldn't do very interesting
let's make another file
secondary file here
it's another CTE I'm not gonna talk
about headers today and let's say this
just hold the function called bacon yeah
just prints bacon a new line there and
of course this uses C it helps so we're
going to do die or a string so we have a
function called bacon in this file and
we also want to compile it
yeah I'll it on this belly you can also
do dot o or - oh here and give your file
different name like I wanna name it
Prague for example now instead of a dot
executable it's gonna be Prague dot txt
and it's gonna use these two files to
build it
so now Marisa make and watch it go see
ya Prague dot exe move out again but now
we've got a run Prague dot exe and we
get the same thing so oh here's last tip
last tape I promise and I'm done I
finished this might yell at me because
I'm having to open already in a while
alright last tip God take God
three of this so I'm just over this
whole full-time little studio that way
we can see so if you want to use
something from another CPP usually you
do it through a header structure but
another way you can do it is if it's
something you're compiling with others
this there's this external a bacon and
you just tell it about it and then you
what's called bacon bet you didn't know
that
alright let's remake this thing unprimed
unn I'm done so I promised I would tell
you how to get this cool background well
I will tell you there it is
it's from wall Haven CC well Haven da CC
not sponsored it's just basically a
bunch of awesome wallpapers so enjoy
okay well I'm out see in the next video
thanks for watching
don't forget to have a good day